what's going on everybody welcome to the
6th matplotlib tutorial video in this
video what we're talking about is pie
charts so pie charts are a lot like the
stack plots that we just showed only
instead of showing maybe over time like
a like a stack plot does this just shows
a slice of time no pun intended
or was it anyway so what we're going to
do now is we'll go ahead and delete
basically all of this that'll be good
and we can leave this I suppose um let's
just do kind of think of easiest way to
go through this we'll just say like
slices ok slices will equal and let's
just do like a slice here so we'll do
let's do let's do this final slice here
so we'll say the slices were 7 2 2 and
13 and then the activities activities
would be equal to we had sleeping eating
working and then playing okay now that's
all we need to make a pie so we have to
make a pie it's simple PLT pie BAM then
what we have is we've got our slices and
then we've got our labels will equal
activities and then we can also specify
colors if we want but we can we can do
that so we'll say colors here calls and
that will also equal a list and I forget
what we had before but cyan magenta red
and black I think might have been the
right order so we'll do that and we'll
say colors equals
we'll just go with that for now and
let's go ahead and run that that doesn't
work
colors equals Cole's is what we said try
again alright so now we've got our pie
chart we don't really need this legend
actually it's pretty obvious on here and
we also need the while and X labels
let's get rid of that stuff for now
let's just comment that out okay
so we've got the colors the other thing
I wouldn't mind is you can set like
right now I believe it's the default the
starting angle but no we don't actually
have that done so one thing you can do
is you can kind of set like where it
starts
so we could say start angle equals 90s
so we can start at a 90 degree angle so
you'll see right here the top is like
this 90 degree angle okay
so just keep that in mind and then the
rest of this stuff is plotted basically
it's plotted counterclockwise so you
start at that 90 degree angle it starts
plotting sleeping than it does eating
working playing and it goes
counterclockwise so the next thing that
we could do is like right now you'll see
that we've kind of got this
I don't know this chart I guess it's
kind of like oblong a little bit and we
can talk a little bit about that later
but for now we'll just let that go and
so we can close out of this and like one
thing that we can do is like when it's
all like kind of like shaped like that
one thing you could do is like shadow
and we can say the shadow equals true so
this will add a bit of a shadow to it so
it just kind of looks more reasonable
with what we're doing there another
thing that you can see that charts will
sometimes do is that we'll pull out like
a piece of the pie so to speak so one
thing that you can do there is you can
use this term explode and this will
explode the elements in the manner that
you're kind of suggesting so we could
explode let's explode eating so we could
explode by zero zero point one zero zero
so there you go kind of pulls out that
like little eating slice a little bit to
give us some some more like I don't know
draws your attention to that eating
slice basically so we can close out of
that also the other thing you can do is
you can have the percentages on there so
what I'm going to go ahead and do is
I'll and we could hit enter here so each
of these little things is on their own
line
so we're exploding there now what we can
do is we can say Auto PCT and what this
does is adds the percentage to the pie
so we'll say Auto PCT equals and then
here is just the code for it
percentage 1 point 1 F % percent don't
worry about what it means it's just
going to add a percentage to the pie so
let's go ahead and do that real quick
and our percentages are now on the each
little respective slice of course
playing the labels black so we can't see
it so maybe we could change that color
let's change black to blue and now we'll
at least be able to see it anyway there
it is
so there you go and what's nifty about
this is these numbers were in ours if
you recall it adds up to 24 hours but
the calculation of like the pies slice
size is done automatically for you so
that's actually really useful you don't
have to be the one that calculates the
percentage or the slice of the pie it
does all that all on its own so that's
pretty cool anyway that's about all I
want to show with pie graphs just a few
nifty little things you can do you can
look up some more there's a few other
things you can do with pie charts and
stuff but that's good enough for now so
anyways if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time